can you imagine calling a personal
injury lawyer
the
i was wearing a shirt we were uh we
didn't take your shirt off on the beach
no we didn't go to the beach we went to
uh she got us a like a groupon for one
of those paddle bikes like kind of what
water boxer does except it's like a bike
you sit on so we just went around the
marina it was fun
i know you think i'm crazy but it was a
marine adult right here deal with them
you said yeah i see you i see what
you're doing i see it's a [ __ ]
amazing thing you're a strong man joe he
couldn't go into the ocean
he could take a shirt with a [ __ ]
paddleboard about the [ __ ] marina and
there was no sharks there when i needed
him
next time you're doing that let me know
i'll put tuna fish in your pocket
[ __ ] i'll call [ __ ] the jaws
whatever his name dude
what's up with you player man just
chilling just came from work and i'm
just headed traffic was easy i thought
it was going to be worse and i just
made it here and i'm glad to be here man
and i like [ __ ] with joy diaz i
forgot you good good good no no no
that's tremendous now
do you shoot every week or you're just
writing the six episodes uh we're just
writing the six right now and we're
gonna start shooting in a few
weeks
and we should be done by let's say july
and it's going to air in august
and uh yeah it should be fun we over at
the fox lot and just
[ __ ] on the fox lot how [ __ ] great
is it to walk on the fox lot especially
for me i got felonies
they have no [ __ ] idea yeah they got
shrimp out and ham and cheese sandwiches
now you are mingling
taking [ __ ] housing things it's funny
because they had uh like the peanut gang
characters like walking around during
lunch times they're taking photos with
them
like i don't know who's in the costume
and they don't know who they're taking
photos with says [ __ ] it it's like it's
whatever it's great to just walk around
the fire and it's
my favorite lot is paramount that's the
one where i walk on the lot and i'm like
damn right i can't believe they let me
in
without a [ __ ] security guy on me
like i'm just walking around like it's
it's uh
i'm the first audition i went through
was on the fox slot and i had to walk to
the other [ __ ] end because the
the building that belongs to the dude
who wrote nypd blue
at that time that [ __ ] had a
building damn but it was all the way at
the end and you don't know you got a
shirt on lee that's your son's beauty
that's a huge yeah that's a hot lot
that's a hot one that's a sun that's
like a it quite a lot the sun hits that
[ __ ] like no i'm gonna tell you what
right sony sony really yes yeah
culver city right there century city
culver city yeah on uh what street is
that uh
washington or something yeah washington
that live dog i had a [ __ ] neo see in
the old days they would let you park and
then walk around the lot cross over and
you're right there
i think after 9 11 they'd make you cross
on that side you can cross across
washington and go through so i was used
to that easy pimp [ __ ] right and often
they switch it on my ass
and the hottest day of [ __ ] april
like a march you know one of those hot
days that happens in l.a i have a black
velour mafia sweatshirt
pants [ __ ] with no underwear on and i
can feel the balls dripping on the
velour you're just dripping by the time
oh my god i got to that audition it was
a spider-man 2. oh [ __ ] i'll never
forget that i was drenched and i got in
there there was 30 gangsters in there
and i'm like i'm not getting this i
don't even know where i'm staying
this is a waste of my [ __ ] time but i
got so wound up and so scared from
looking at these [ __ ] but i
just went in there and got it like just
stole it like i said [ __ ] it i am not
letting these [ __ ] take the
first i sweat all the way here [ __ ] this
oh my god i was sweating profusiously
though
it might be a little bit different for
you joey because you went on auditions
but like ian how many times did you walk
by the fox drive by the fox a lot and
now you're like where it must be crazy
like that's i worked in tv for a few
years and the only i worked on sunset
and gower a lot which is gross
like i never got to work on like a nice
like fox cb like one of those lots
that's like the one thing i wish i had
done it it's always kind of amazing the
thing about the paramount like you
mentioned i remember
like walking on that lot with humor you
know hugh moore comic he's from yeah
yeah yeah yeah i know he was okay
and then you know paramount has that big
blue backdrop like just sitting on the
lot and they shoot things there or up
against it and then one day we was
walking there i forgot why we were there
we weren't
i think we were about to
to interview for jobs some writing jobs
and he said it's a beautiful day isn't
it i said what do you mean
and he's like any day you could walk on
the paramount lot is a beautiful day and
i said oh [ __ ] he's right we're winning
right now whether we get these jobs or
not
because this is what we came here to do
and like we were in the vicinity of it
so it's like all right cool
you know i really like you i always like
you because you're a gentleman and lee i
love i could tell you this with [ __ ]
there's not too many things that bring
me pleasure in life
i can't lie to you most of the times i'm
sitting there where's the
where's the [ __ ] gun
nothing gets my dick harder when i look
at that audition it says i got to go to
paramount fox
sony
gow a lot that's disgusting you're
absolutely right sunset not sunset gal
but yeah even some tech guys there's two
of them out of montana
the tribune lot yeah it's a [ __ ]
nightmare i worked over this shitty live
shitty lot yeah but when you're a felon
and you've been in prison
you don't have a [ __ ] agent nobody
wants to manage it the only person who's
giving you spots is mitzi sure right and
all of a sudden hey you want a lot
to go read for [ __ ] you know jazz
bomb and terry or something
nobody has an idea like i haven't being
up till two you know getting it down and
right just when you walk in that lot
you're like [ __ ] if these people knew
that
half the [ __ ] i did they wouldn't let me
on this lot well describe what you see
because like a lot of people like don't
know what like lots are like it's like
huge buildings and they have signs
everywhere and you see like
reserved for like stars like all over
the place it's just it's producers and
there's you know there's sting shooting
it's like the history of [ __ ] you've
seen your entire life things that you
thought you'd never be near and you're
there and it just kind of
blows your mind like i didn't know i'd
get this close have any have you ever
worked on like a stage that had like a
really cool show that you used to watch
it's funny because you guys mentioned
that i was doing two and a half men and
i was just basically an extra a couple
years ago with ashton kutcher when we
were dancing on the street right and it
was boring as [ __ ] man and you know me i
always bring 22 joints right okay what a
lot of money
and during lunch i'll watch something
they got you on camera so you got to
make believe you're smoking a cigarette
and then double fisted
but uh i was smoking a dude one day it
was raining or something that's why i
knew they wouldn't catch me and i went
to one of those coves and i'm smoking
and i'm halfway done with the joint i
looked and they said it had a list on
the wall i was shown so yeah yeah i love
lucy there i put that joint out so
[ __ ] before you get respect out of
respect
where steve burns shot his show remember
he tweeted all the shows they had shot
there yeah there's something to that
yeah there is something there's
something today it gives you you can't
it's something relatable to it because
no matter where you were in the world
you were watching this thing and now
you're aware this thing was shot and it
does strike you a little bit at least a
little bit it gets you a little bit
it's always [ __ ] with me i just don't
let it take over right i just make
believe like it's not happening
like being like at a table reading
there's other people in the room and you
just gotta act like you know this ain't
happening right this [ __ ] this
is normal this guy is not standing 10
feet from me i watch this guy
kill a [ __ ] this movie and this
movie and this movie
it's really [ __ ] surreal i i i
i don't even know how to describe it to
people i can't because i'm embarrassed
i'd rather tell you a story about
stabbing somebody i'm telling you a
story if that's easier being a lot next
to this guy and what i was going through
the hardest lot i was ever around was
shooting the movie with dick van dyke
yeah that old [ __ ] with [ __ ]
little balls under his eyes and [ __ ]
he's old i couldn't keep it together at
all at no point cause i could i keep it
together i was crying
every time i looked at him i had to put
my head down until finally he was like
why is this [ __ ] guy crying bro he's
a big [ __ ] dude what's the problem i
had to tell him what happened
he must go through that a lot though
that must happen all the time like do
you think if like tom cruise doesn't
move it probably takes him a couple days
to calm like all the rest of the actors
down
like you must
you know i don't know
what happened with deniro and stallone
let's just say hello but like it wasn't
maybe it was because they were already
like into the movie but like
it must be crazy like getting to work
with you just say hello you go like that
with your hand and someone will come
over and give you their hand and say
nice to meet you
say yeah and then they ask you a
question you ask them a question and at
the end of the night you go home i don't
talk unless i'm spoken to right you know
that's what i was taught i don't reach
out but you really love you yeah i don't
try that where'd you get that motivation
final say dick right how are you doing
good yeah yeah you ready for this yeah i
am i just try to have a good normal time
and not [ __ ] it up right yeah that's it
that's all you know that's all you're
saying to yourself when you're just
don't [ __ ] it up you're not not even
just like all right just be normal ian
hi
do my thing
and then if they want to talk some more
you know okay and then
and then i'm out
there's some [ __ ] i don't want
to see
because i would have a nervous breakdown
there's certain [ __ ] one of
them would definitely be muhammad ali
really like when we went to the store i
don't know how long you been out here
now uh in cali i've been out here since
like 2000
around 2000 yeah like three or four
years before that i was at the store and
do you remember at the store
lila lee used to hang out yeah one of
his daughters yeah one of his daughters
she comes around once in a while it was
a comic yeah
and i left one night and two days later
they told me dog she came up here
muhammad ali
and i remember going like wow and then
going i don't really really want to see
my mama
i would have a nervous breakdown
yeah you know how would you act around
muhammad ali i i don't know how i would
[ __ ] act
i don't know how i would act i know i
lose i have to hug him
i'd have to hug him after a few [ __ ]
minutes you got to hug the champ you got
to hug him yeah
this i'd hug pete rose
yeah red band said he saw him at the
glen dale mall looking lonely as a
[ __ ] i'd shake his hands yeah i
like that dude yeah me too i would go up
to the baseball that sketches commercial
made me laugh where he wasn't allowed to
be in the hall like his wife yelled at
him
i don't know i hope he gets taken back
they're really campaigning for it now
yeah something is going on
it's it's crazy how quick
we get like used to things like i was
thinking about as i was leaving tonight
i was like i'm headed to work and a year
and a half ago i would have been hating
life and like worried until i was gonna
get home
and now i'm going to have fun and get
high with joey and and ian and that's
your job and it's my job and it's just
so it's like yeah you guys have been on
a ton of lots and it's just but it's
to someone
20 years ago or someone back in new
jersey or new york they must just lose
their mind doc if you would have told me
25 years ago i was going to walk on the
paramount line i would have spit your
[ __ ] like you have a favorite lot can
you think about like that's crazy oh
they got good food
i could mingle on that oh [ __ ] one time
you know patrice yeah please one time
patrice
this is a few years before he died maybe
like three years before he died we were
driving around hollywood he he was in
town we had some meetings and then we
was driving around hollywood we were
gonna go get something to eat
then in the middle of hollywood there
was this lot maybe around not maybe
around like a
vanish there's a slot
and it was set up for like food like for
like a shoot you know and it was lunch
time and then we just like i dare you
that we should go over there and go get
something to eat and he's like bet let's
do it and then we pulled on with the car
said some [ __ ] to the security guy
we drove on and then we got online
at the catering [ __ ] and then we got
some food and we sat down with the
extras and started eating
and then i think it was like one of
those tnt shows like law and art and he
knew one of the the main actors from the
shows and then we moved from the extras
to sit over there and eat with them and
we we could have paid for lunch
somewhere but it was just more fun to
just [ __ ] around and do this thing and
we had lunch and then then we bounced
i've never had that we got some we got
some numbers from somebody the actor the
extra chicks because they use hard
extras free lunch numbers because
everybody thinks y'all doing the same
[ __ ] and then they noticed that people
were paying like please more attention
yeah and then and then we had more
freedom than them because this didn't
mean nothing to us if we got kicked out
it was just gonna add to the story
so we were just looser and they were
just on their best behavior like who's
these loose dudes
i would never have the balls to do that
just the thing that's getting thrown
really and somebody's saying they threw
joe diaz out he tried to get a lunch i
would [ __ ] have a heart attack
everything you've done in here
you can't take a lunch there's a lot of
things that where you draw the line
yeah it's funny man yeah that's [ __ ]
crap i know i don't have the balls to do
it i couldn't get away with it we just
thought this [ __ ] would be fun
it's [ __ ] fun and this is
stereotypical we just thought it would
be fun i said going to somebody's party
when you weren't invited yeah yeah yeah
it was like driving by yeah it's like
driving by and seeing a party
let's take a chance let's go in there
you know you got a bag of wheat just
tell me here let's see what happened
they let you in when people see you with
a drug they like you know how he's all
right he belongs in this park who sent
you he'll invite you i don't know drugs
we went to the supermarket
now how long have you been doing comedy
uh like over 20 years
that's what i tell people
now you're a great writer but how did
you get into the other side of the right
like how long you've been doing that i
was doing stand-up and then uh one time
was in new york i started in new york
and uh
and uh
this guy
rick doffman he used to be a manager
under barry cats had his own company he
was running gotham at the time and he
said hey they're auditioning for writers
for keenan ivorian's talk show
and uh he's like do you want to come
down and do a set for this lady and
she'll determine if you're good enough
to be a writer on the show i was like i
bet you know and then uh
i went down there that night and i was
hot back then like i had a set
that was getting standing o's
if i did it like it was a hot 10. like i
i thrown away all my old [ __ ] started
working on this thing at the boston
comedy club and like built it up and it
and then there was a point where i was
worried i was doing the boston so much i
wasn't even doing black clubs but then
we had this black comedy
competition in jersey and i drove all my
friends at night
we i was looking for park and they all
jumped out the car ran into the contest
venue wrote their names down and when i
walked in there's like we all signed up
so then i signed up last i said you
[ __ ] i drove you here i got to
drive you back home and you didn't sign
my name on the list so i'm last so
everybody goes there's a hot show
everybody does good and i stand them
with my tent i said oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
works anywhere this is dope so then i
got on deaf comedy jam with that set and
i also did that set for this lady
at the gotham and uh she was like you
got any writing samples i was like yeah
i got some writing samples and i had
some ideas written down and i had some
completely written out and the only
reason why i had them completely written
out is
a few years earlier a homeboy am i
another comic arnold acevedo i don't
know if you know anna acevedo it's a
puerto rican dude it's from westbury
long island and we used to do a lot of
shows together and we all hung out and
we you know after our shows we just hang
out on the corner and just talk and just
laugh for hours you know what i'm saying
and i don't know how the topic came up
but he was like yeah man i got
362 sketches
and i'm like what
he had 362 sketches like why he said
just in case i get a job on snl i don't
have to come up with a new sketch every
week i got sketches and i was like oh
[ __ ] i don't have no sketches i'm like
how the [ __ ] am i going to get 300 or
something sketches
and i was like calm down ian i panicked
at first inside
i'm just pretending to still be in this
conversation with these dudes we're
having fun with but on the inside i'm
panicked because i'm like i'm unprepared
for this comedy life or for the
possibilities that this thing could
branch out into now i was like calm down
just when you always have ideas but you
just never write them down you promise
to write them down you never do so next
time you have an idea either write the
go home write it down on a piece of
paper go home and completely finish it
or at least jot it down so that you
don't forget it and then it'll
accumulate up to uh then i calm down so
then i started doing that and then this
opportunity came along years later and
it was like 2 000 it's on 99 so i had to
i went home that night finished like six
sketches i had three wrote three and
faxed them in
and then it was like and it was like
december mid-december and i waited to
hear from him for like two weeks like
you got the job come out here in january
and i just
came out
and did the [ __ ] then the show got
canceled three months later
yeah and you've been here ever since
yeah you know
the first few years here like the first
three years i like i love new york so
much i'm like new york you know i love
new york
and you you don't want when you once
you're from new york you're proud of
that title i'm from new york you know
and uh i was here so i spent
i spent most of my time in new york even
though i had an apartment here and then
i said to myself yeah you got to be in
la to do the [ __ ] you want to do
you can't like be in new york
just
doing what you use you have an apartment
in l.a and you came there and i and i
and i decided to stay because one night
after the show got canceled me and hugh
moore was driving around because he was
writing on uh
on uh the show that chris spencer had
that sinbad took over and we so we write
on competitive shows and we both from
new york and uh we was playing mob deep
in the car one night
and then
there's a line in the song that i never
paid attention before and hugh moore
repeated it he said scared money don't
make money and that was
the sign from
god or the universe to say stay in la
because when the show got cancelled
there was like three weeks left on my
contract
and there's a guaranteed contract up to
a certain amount of weeks and then so
then i got paid nine thousand dollars
for free
right so i had
so i had like nine thousand dollars plus
whatever money i was making in comedy in
new york so maybe i had twelve thousand
dollars the most amount of money i ever
had in my life
and i was like i can go back to new york
and do shows and i'll definitely get
shows because i always was getting shows
and i could add to the twelve thousand
dollars or i can scared money don't make
no money getting up get an apartment
here pay rent and stay here and see if i
can get another writing job which i have
no connections to anybody but i just
have a feeling if i stick around if i
stick around i'll get jobs things will
happen so then i just did that i just
listened to the mob
lyric and i just stayed and sometimes a
sign yeah i live on science too man
always have
something sways me i don't know
it's i i came out here on the same thing
i came out here to shoot a pilot shot
the pilot didn't get picked up right i
had a choice and i said well if i shot a
pilot let's see what else we could
boogie i'll give it six more months
gotta taco bell commercial gave it a
little more time got this got that and
you [ __ ] stay you know you're like
what the [ __ ] am i doing somewhere else
i only my tenure in new york
was maybe four or five months and 94.
i was
terrible i was at the new york comedy
club with al uh i went down to boston
and you [ __ ] scared me down in
fourth street dave chappelle was there
all right anymore it was time i just
said get me the [ __ ] out of here nick
depaulo was down on the monday night i
was like i don't belong here and then i
went to uh but my club was in new york i
[ __ ] the lucian a little bit
he pissed me off and i [ __ ] with the
dude the other one that was he was
supposed to get a deal from warner
brothers whatever happened to those
fools
the guy on like 76th street on the west
side that's uh that's him and his wife
i know you're talking about god damn
yeah they called me one night stand up
new york stand up new york the old
owners called me one night and said
there's a big thing going on in new york
you should fly back this week josh will
fly back
and did the festival for them for free
and
something with a festival they were
trying to start that all this industry
was going to be there it just sounded
too kinky to me
and then i'd see him at the comedy store
al something no no no they always see
him and his wife right i know you're
talking about i just wanted classes
there or something
they did something there [ __ ] crazy
that was a but new york was what
kick-started my career because i saw
something
i saw
john leguizamo doing time a year old
triple in this old dump on like the
the in hell's kitchen and they started
their open mic at midnight right in 93
[ __ ] midnight who start to open mic
at midnight but they're like people like
yeah there's like eight people there i
went in there it was just drunk
[ __ ]
trying to get dollar fifty beers or
something
and there's comics on stage and i'm like
this isn't what i signed up for at that
age at that time i didn't know this was
it i didn't know this was what you did
so i never went back
and then i read something and i talked
to somebody at a club and you're like
yeah man you got to go to those places
that's where you bomb and i went down
there i was driving a limo
and i went to kennedy airport and on the
way back i stopped and then i seen john
legere's armor on stage and i said
i got it all right i'm gonna pack my
bags go back to colorado and work on
this [ __ ] mm-hmm and that's when i
really really got serious so you went to
colorado i didn't know that i started in
denver oh i said i know that i started
in them in 91 but i was like selling
drugs right getting my dick sucked i was
doing open mic on tuesdays i was the
host all i had to do was five minutes
and i could do blow and
sell pills at this place
i took it seriously but i didn't right i
was just i was just killing time i just
come out of prison
i couldn't i had a felony i didn't know
what i wanted to do but this seemed
attractive i didn't know about that
traveling right right being on the road
like bob seeger and [ __ ] [ __ ] you
sleeping in hotels i like my bed but
right but then people said this we got
they got to travel we got to do this you
got to do that this is what needs to be
done so
yeah i just i just didn't want to do a
regular job
and so that's that's what it appealed to
me
i didn't i didn't mind the travel i
might mind it now but i know it's
necessary i'm going to have to do a
bunch of traveling to get this thing to
where i want it to get to you know what
i mean to be just so independent that i
can call my own shots
so
i'm down
depending on what career you want right
to have
you have a great career but you also
have something else you're also very
funny mm-hmm
and uh for you to take over this
[ __ ] like you're supposed
you got to get allies right so you got
to go to every state and get one
representative
edwards this is the baddest [ __ ]
smoothest black dude working right now
nomination you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] billy dee williams he's done it's
hilarious and little by little bam bam
bam and all of a sudden you have these
little ports that got you it's like when
you these presidents isn't the big thing
[ __ ] iowa yeah they get the signs
like [ __ ] momos and they're out there
a bunch of white people vote for this
[ __ ] idiot same thing with stand up
right we got to get out there right it's
hard it's rough on your family it's
rough on you at a certain age but it's
also fun right it's rough till you get
to your hotel room right and now you go
into work mode now you're going to
animal mode you know this is where i am
last time i was here i got my dick
sucked i went to this place they got
good wings let's talk about those wings
let's talk about the dirty hoes in this
town let's talk about this let's talk
about that now you become a bond at that
time and you keep building this time you
go you sell 300 tickets the next time
it's 4.50 the next time now you haven't
been in a year and a half so now you
guys double up and get 800 tickets right
you're ready for a small theater
now you got to go back and get that hump
over now you're ready for a thousand
seater and this is it but
i don't i was talking to josh wolfe this
morning and he was asking me how i felt
and i told him for me right now at this
part of my life i didn't think i'd be
doing this ian right i didn't think i'd
be picking up my package and going to
salt lake city into denver and to boston
but this is it right this is what we
signed up for whether you're 52 or 22.
this is what you signed up for
so i've fallen in love with it right
again i because of the social media
aspect of it right i'm seeing
[ __ ] i communicate with avalon
what do they call that [ __ ] avatar
avatar avalon avatar whatever the [ __ ]
it is and also they are in front of you
shaking your [ __ ] hand
so the experience came through right it
really came full circle this thing that
started on a [ __ ] wire
this is on a wire we're doing this whole
show on a [ __ ] wire right this is a
wire
we have put our videos on this [ __ ]
wine
20 years ago a comic richard probably
couldn't go home and put his setup in
the comments throwing a wire right if
you're serious about this game
you could put your setup every night on
the [ __ ] youtube right and it's the
same thing as going on the road you're
picking up allies that's a different
avenue right you know you do a comedy
central special tommy central airs it
friday twice and once on sunday and then
what are you gonna they're gonna go
backwards and go on show time who has
show time who has show time who has
shows yeah [ __ ] people with perverts
that want the whole thing with the
blonde chick that comes out and talks to
you that chick's hot she saved my life
in hotels a couple of times that little
blanche she's like just like felicia
michaels
if you close your eyes you think it's
[ __ ] felicia michael
who this girl on showtime
and they do a half hour show and she
does the whole show naked oh katie
morgan i think i think that's her name
really cute blonde squeaky voice yeah
and she talks about sucking dick and
eating ass and she plays video and
she'll talk about the history of finger
banging mm-hmm and it goes back to the
case of fingerboard yeah i love that
no this is listen
[ __ ]
i didn't think i'd be on the [ __ ]
road at this age right
i thought i would just be collecting
checks from the sitcom i did as the
neighbor right right i just done the
seven year run on the neighbor down that
[ __ ] uh
what's my fate there's another studio i
like cbs radford that damn like i just
went to cbs rap in the studio city what
do you want for lunch joe how about a
little sushi dang chicken teriyaki white
meat
and double up on the salad a few pieces
of albacore because that's how they roll
over there right that's what i thought
but no it didn't turn out that way so
but sometimes you want to go to china
but you end up in [ __ ] japan right so
it's the same difference this [ __ ] is
just more powerful i love it like this
this is why you this is a bad
[ __ ] that's why it helps me
not have to depend on somebody else
telling me who i'm gonna be how far i'm
gonna get and and and there's beauty in
this why it's like control your own
destiny in this world there's no more
excuses there's no more excuses in this
i don't give a [ __ ] whether you live in
a touch in new jersey or [ __ ] iowa
you want to do something now on this on
this whole thing you want to show me
what you got it's a it's a you know what
if you got an iphone now you go on
periscope and show me what you got yeah
it's that simple if you're that good
you'll shine through yeah it's that
[ __ ] simple you could go into
training now at the age of nine you
could do a show in your [ __ ] bedroom
if you're nine look at cassius smoothie
what does that say in five years cash is
more is gonna be [ __ ] uh
uh johnny carson you know
but it adds a lot of pressure though
what's the pressure
that now you don't have an excuse a lot
of people don't like you don't have an
excuse yeah you don't have this you know
the cream rises to the crop but whoever
was making excuses then see you later
and then the people that don't care
about excuses about going out there and
getting it they they'll get
it the only thing is sometimes some
people have more balls than talent
but i can't get mad at somebody with
more balls and talent
at least they're using their balls
that's how i look at it that it's all
mixed in some way or another you know
you say whatever you want to say this
kid made ten hundred million dollars
what's the
you can't touch this
can't touch this
hammer yeah that [ __ ] used to
sell albums in front of the comedy store
people coming over
no way she will tell you those door
people tell you the stories they still
remember him you know he was a bat boy
for [ __ ] the oakland a's
you know this sometimes you hear these
stories
and this is what it uh lee
where the [ __ ] were we we were talking
about the desire uh ian tell me about
the desire to be good at stand up what
goes through your heart what goes
through your soul when you sign your
name and your last on the [ __ ] list
and you see a dude up on stage that's
killing him at the end of your [ __ ]
open mic thing and you're funnier than
he is but you can't tell them what to
desire how many times do you want to go
on stage what do you think about all day
do you think about anything else when
you want to [ __ ] be good at comedy
it's like
it's there's something like you're in a
job where you have to kind of prove
yourself
every time you get on stage and you have
to accept that this is what i do i got
to prove myself
and
the desire to like this is a funny thing
where
if you don't do as much as you can
somebody will catch you from behind and
if you don't do as much as you can
you'll never catch the people ahead of
you
and
so you just always have to stay on your
toes and keep working and keep grinding
keep writing and trying to figure out
ways how to to to gain inches on the
person on in front of you and on the
person
behind you but you have to love to want
to do that you know you you got to love
to want to accomplish something then
it's for you then then it's easier you
know what i mean like i always want to
be funny like i like hanging around with
young comics
i think more than it's like some older
comics they get like bit or they just
get tired and wear down like young
comics ex inspire me like oh these
people are hungry and they look up to me
so i don't want them to never not look
up to me like the way i'm not looking up
to this older guy who's just like just
mailing it in so
i just just wan i don't i don't i don't
know i think
right now because i'm not where i want
to be i'm still hungry but i hope
when i get to where i want to be that i
stay hungry as i am now what i love
about where i'm at now is the fact that
i'm still hungry and like that that
itself is a gift that i enjoy
i'm hungry and a [ __ ] you know
yeah
yeah that's why i love you like wheels
are always [ __ ] turning yeah uh if i
have an idea for somebody i'll pass on
the karma amen i was watching on stage
i think you should really [ __ ] jump
off a building whatever the [ __ ] you do
i love watching you you know
ever since i went back to the comedy
store i was trying to explain to my
friend jody today
that your game improves i've said it on
the podcast many times you're at the
world's best at least the top three
uh
places to do stand-up comedy this is it
this is this is it you're a [ __ ]
you're a texas you're an army ranger
you're a navy seal you're you're a
[ __ ] you're the best of the best you
know and
i i couple nights i went there and
watched you and i was blown away by you
thanks blown away from the abortion joke
to no commitment you know you've got
three things going on that you have
broken the joke down
i would love to aspire to write like
somebody like you
it is are you kidding me joey do you say
this god and you're smooth
you're smooth which i really like i like
people
that come around the back door and make
you think but [ __ ] your world up
you make them think and [ __ ] their world
up i come at you joe rogan comes at you
it's a no-brainer
it's a different type of energy your
energy is very
it's jazz
it's jazz
it's and you know what it's jamaican
jazz
which doesn't exist is you
the smoothness in your voice and how
your tones and you stop that's the gift
right that's the gift that people don't
know the power of the voice and stand up
mm-hmm is what don't hit you till about
the 12th year right when you realize how
powerful your voice is well which one
you don't listen and then when i get
loud it's too
that the power of the mind and i know it
i don't know how to teach it to you if
you came to me lee and said don't i want
to be the best stand up i was watching
the other night and what you do with
your voice your voice controls the game
that's why they give you the microphone
that's why i [ __ ] up and walk away from
the microphone when you walk away from
the microphone you lose your power
that power is but your voice and comedy
and your thing like when i close my eyes
it's like uh
julia's serving
the rhythm is in the damn i'll take that
yeah
you're the the smoothness
and i've never heard that type of
smoothness there's a guy that has that
smoothness but it's a complete different
smoothness and that's dave chappelle
right right it's a complete different
smoothness you took it somewhere else so
it's really that's what i see man well
thanks man in my comedy world i like i
like but i'm a student of the game right
i want to see what makes you tick and i
want to see why they're laughing right
you know what i'm saying i want to see
why i didn't laugh let's see why they
[ __ ] really laughing are they his
words if people knew that your words
don't even matter right people if people
knew at home it's like when people said
i love intelligent comedy and thoughtful
i like in comedy that what they say that
incites my brain when they go suck a
dick that smells like ass that'll make
you [ __ ] think
all right
you know what i'm saying that'll make
you suck a dick that smells like yeah
why is this guy's dick smells like ass
as you're sucking it that's his 54 000
question right there
but it's uh
i love stand up man i've always loved it
and the more i do it the more respect i
have for it right i have a ton of
respect for it i've never run a light
i've never done a respect
like that
i have a ton of respect for it because
it took me out of a dark place it took
me out of a gutter i respected i
respected like a [ __ ]
lion i respect that comedy store stage
i know what's happened to me you know i
never went to juilliard right i ain't no
[ __ ] who's the big black dude
i didn't go to jail if i went to
juilliard i didn't go to juilliard i
didn't take no acting classes when i was
in new york you know what acting was
[ __ ] fronting with drugs your life
that's your life acting is when you go
up to people and say don't let me 20
i'll bring back in an hour i got this
check what's coming this dude i saw them
an encyclopedia and they gave me the 20.
that's acting
uh and then you are in a [ __ ] room
with you know the director from
drugstore cowboy and john travolta's in
the room and they i thought about that
today because battlestar galactica was
what's that movie travolta made about
the scientologist uh about something
earth
battle earth something like that i was
bro me and billy gladdel were about to
get hired to be travolta's
sidekicks in a movie about a singer from
hoboken new jersey that disrespected
sinatra
and drew store jimmy roselli
disrespected frank sinatra they didn't
sing at his mother jimmy roselli was
petrified us or not
sinatra was petrified of roselli he had
a better voice than sinatra and his
mother would always talk about jimmy
rozelle you got to be more like jimmy
roselli so when sinatra busted out he
hired jimmy rosalia to sing at his
mother's thing he never showed up oh so
he said really i'm cutting you off he
cut him off so bad that jimmy roselli
you sell albums from the trunk of his
car in all broken new jersey damn and
the italians would go jimmy close the
trunk you're embarrassed
so we had that [ __ ] movie
and i'll never forget dawg i went to the
comedy store on a sunday mm-hmm
and got [ __ ] up like blow in the whole
[ __ ] thing eating somebody's ass like
three in the morning just a normal
tuesday and this and i had a call back
for this and i had gone over it
i knew it but that [ __ ] cocaine and
all that party and threw this [ __ ] off
and i went in there monday at 10 o'clock
and i thought it was gonna be me and who
directed cocaine cowboy you know
documentary no no the the movie movie
with matt dillon vanzant badass
[ __ ] he did something after that
wasn't bad i thought it was just going
to be gus van zandt
[ __ ] no it was travaulted oh [ __ ] at 10
15 oh he said after the night you had
after the night i got travolta got to
show up in this [ __ ]
and i remember i had to go in there
first and he was great and i did great
and they called my agent and they said
you know what we got a pen in them and
two days later my agent goes you got a
spot tonight somewhere they want to come
see you guys van zant and the casting
director mm-hmm i said yeah at the
comedy store and they [ __ ] showed up
this man said shook my hand
he said listen i'll be seeing you soon
and i'm in miami doing the improv
feeling good about myself i'm about to
do a travolta movie and my [ __ ]
manager calls me because dog he took
battlefield galactico
over [ __ ] some scientology movie over
your movie it's over it got written the
script is done nothing they never did it
again i mean he had to take that movie
he had to take battlefield earth yeah
they showed pictures and playing with
little filming asian boys
playing soccer with little asian boys
with [ __ ] thongs on they know all his
secrets
yeah you have to take it who would tell
somebody that's how they got you seen
the scientology documentary i'll tell
you what this is how they come to you
though they don't you don't tell them
[ __ ] at first
they come to you once you're sucking
some dude's dick he's going to take out
like a little iphone and go somebody
wants to talk to you on telescope
and it's that old dude gel ron hubbard
going listen we got you we got cameras
all over that room we got a dildo up
your ass that's going to be [ __ ] up
when we show the pictures to welcome
back college
you better be up at 4 4 4 lows for lease
tomorrow
bring an envelope and bring a notebook
remember he took the courses did you see
that they talked yeah he took the
courses he was in you know you know
what's funny about that documentary like
the first
two
courses in
in scientology are actually legit
like if you break it down it's like any
religion like every religion has like
roots of truth
and then
after that they just make [ __ ] up
and to me when i was watching the
scientists this this could have actually
been a decent
honest religion but then they started
making up levels so that you can pay
more money to get to those levels and it
was a point of like pride and esteem for
people to get to those levels and then
you get to the briefcase level where
they just open this briefcase and they
tell you this crazy ass story that
couldn't be true and you were worse off
at that level than you were in level one
and level two if you didn't just tapped
out right then and there but they just
made this [ __ ] up for money but the
first two things it has to be believable
enough
to get you in and you're like every time
you're growing up you're like but the
first two levels were legit so the rest
of the [ __ ] even though it feels hokey
it it should be all right and same thing
christianity does or just most religions
it's like you know the first the first
few things
like this is solid then it gets go you
keep going up it's that's when [ __ ] gets
crazy but you believe them because of
the first two
have you guys ever got tested i've been
here four and a half years and i just
like two weeks ago got asked no i didn't
get tested someone asked me on the
street if i wanted to and you kept
walking at home hell yeah yeah i'd never
do it it's like santoria one minute
you're throwing some cards next to me up
in the bronx naked getting water poured
on you by three black dudes playing
drums
first two levels of santa maria
century is good
that's right we got to do a little
[ __ ] uh
tony bennett break it up a little bit
and [ __ ] we do this every monday
all right
i want to be around
to
pick up the piece that's a badass jam
i like this dude
i like tony bennett because he never
panicked
you know what i mean his whole creators
never panic he just got older at all i'm
just gonna keep doing this [ __ ] paid
yeah he's like a hundred do me a favor
play the beginning of i left my heart in
san francisco doug this song i play this
every monday
uh
monday morning as i'm getting ready
and sometimes i i'm doing [ __ ] and the
next song falls in because it's the
greatest hits out
and it's a i left my heart in san
francisco you gotta hear the first
[ __ ] verse of this all right he
knocks us out of the park though
knocks that apart
too much
sorry
don't touch nothing [ __ ]
finger
that's a bad dude dog yeah
he's gangster
that's a bad [ __ ] right there
that guy takes it to the next level for
a white dude that's hilarious he's
[ __ ] singing songs of lady gaga who's
uglier
never seen them standing together who
the [ __ ] where's that ugly contest
it's [ __ ] up hilarious they both got
hooked noses
you know you know you break out of coke
rock around those two vacuums to see
what happens yeah it looks like she got
on a tony bennett costume
like who's who oh my god but i like him
man because he stuck around he's like
like he had to weather out sinatra and
just everybody else music changing and
he's like
i'm just
i'm just gonna keep doing this [ __ ] i'm
never
keep this tuxedo and then and then he
kind of won
he went through a lot he weathered a lot
of music genres changes bigger stars
than him but this [ __ ] kind of
won and then he started singing duets
with bono and yeah he just started doing
[ __ ] duets with people it's it's
no you really gotta hand it to him yeah
some people just weather it the [ __ ] out
yeah how many times have you been like
how does tony benny think it's going to
go away and it's a decade after decade
after decade you're like tony bennett's
household you know why
because he stays out there yeah
even if he ain't singing you know he
stays out there he's probably out there
three weekends a month yeah probably has
it down one show
you know 52 dollars a ticket he sings
for 45 minutes he gets the [ __ ] out of
that mm-hmm and he goes back to his
hotel room he goes to sleep he takes
care of himself he probably has a train
and he eats well he's like you know
those guys how old is tony bennett
let's see how old that [ __ ] is
and let's see where he is this weekend
he's like when frank sinatra dies
they're gonna need someone to sing old
music
and i'm just going to be alive and i'm
going to be the dude
and
he made it it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] amazing
all right so he's born in 26. so he's 74
there 74 and 15 is what 89 he's about to
turn 90 he's about to turn oh no he's
about to turn 89 in august when is he
traveling where is he this weekend let's
see he's [ __ ] always somewhere dog
i guarantee he's some [ __ ] casino
jumping up and down this water
oh [ __ ] he's in uh london
he's in london with lady gaga oh [ __ ]
and then he's going to atlantis with
lady gaga new york at radio city music
hall so they have an album together or
some [ __ ] i think they were in vegas
what wasn't token listening there in
vegas together
i knew they did a song but they have an
album again something i don't know
they're they're going all over the count
monte carlo [ __ ] 90.
[ __ ] 90. belgium italy and he's in
london tonight doing a show the flight
somebody said they bumped into him in
lax
somebody saw him some friend of mine
said dog i saw tony benny it looked like
a million bucks all right that's what it
is those guys
you know walsh would have been cleaning
up not cosby cosby was doing shows with
a hundred tickets i went to see him he
went to see him he was cleaning up and
how long does he do he sits the whole
thing like a while he's like i went to
like the taping of his special he he did
like almost i think two hours two and a
half hours how was that special
the one i saw was great the one they put
out sucked
he he did two hours they had to condense
it
but uh
i i blew it i wanted to see him and some
of my friends went to see him and then i
said i'll get a chance to see him and
then the scandal dropped he's still
doing some gigs though yeah
i should look it up and go see him
before
before he got no more shows
before somebody gives them one of those
cosby pills and [ __ ]
yeah before yeah it's
hilarious that's what they should change
it to
oh the cosby pill oh my god
i've gotten women [ __ ] up
i've never given them a cosby pill you
know i'm saying like i don't have the
balls to do that because they're gonna
know when they wake up in the morning
right right and you're gonna [ __ ] them
and they're gonna feel their [ __ ]
[ __ ] up
you know what are you gonna do just what
happened i don't know
my [ __ ] hurts i got a [ __ ] up thing
in my eye
you know what happened last night
because i used to do creepy [ __ ] like
coming to ham when they're sleeping and
[ __ ]
i'll do creepy [ __ ] though once i bang
them and then like my dick would get
hard like an hour later they'd be past
that right i go back in that room and
like open up their legs look at that
little monkey gonna try to bang one and
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] [ __ ] that way i'd
love to be like on cnn like
another joey diaz accuser
there's no enjoying these excuses
but i could never
give somebody i remember when the
roofies were big right i used to hang
out with a girl that liked taking off
around split one
which black one
in boulder
damn that's [ __ ] crazy but i've never
put in some chick's drink i'd be [ __ ]
embarrassed that's not my game
i would never poison somebody like that
i don't mind poisoning the league giving
them out of the lion
[ __ ] no we all know you don't mind doing
that
and i don't think lee would mind it
either i could take a break
wouldn't be that bad
it's uh
i don't know man i just uh and i've
known you for a while but i didn't go to
the store so i didn't see you as much
right yeah you you you stopped coming
through
didn't i i didn't see you
and then but you know after the changes
you know the tommy out thing
and you and rogan came back
and just breathed like fresh air into
the store man it's a great place it's a
great place now like some of that
darkness that
it had more darkness
because but you need some of the
darkness
to create that atmosphere that the
stories but some of it is lifted so it
has the right mix mix of like
light and darkness
the store does need some type of
darkness the darkness is what pulls the
comedy out of you right if you let the
store get into you like that late night
sets and you go down there four nights a
week and you let me tell you something
it'll pull some [ __ ] out of you that you
don't know who's in there right because
this is the way i used it i had to
follow moony so by the time i got up
there and heard everything
they had heard everything gee so now you
got to talk to them about what the [ __ ]
was going on
and in that there's pearls of wisdom
right they're tough to get to
but it's a different angle i love being
under pressure with 200 eyeballs on them
that's my world
that's when i can really kick it in
especially if i smoke a little bit and
i'm just kicking back in that stance
it's going to be a [ __ ] long night
for you
but the store taught me that right the
darkness of the store listen they don't
a [ __ ] just no regular people become
comedians right no regular people become
from comedians if you come from a normal
[ __ ] childhood you don't become a
comedian somewhere along the lines
something's stung you and you're trying
to work it out you don't even know it's
stinging right that's the weird thing
about tommy you don't even know you know
and uh there you are for me i don't know
what the [ __ ] it was you said you made
up your mind you didn't want a [ __ ]
day job i'll tell you what neither did i
right and this was i'm telling you
honest this was the
path of least resistance at that time
right right right when i was 31 years
old this was it i had nothing i had
nothing at that time i got divorced i
blew all my credit cards you know there
was no more nobody would front me no
more pills there was no coke dealers
left i couldn't rob nobody they blame it
on me you rocked everybody i know i left
the rock there was no drug dealers left
to rob in boulder and i had to do
something
and i knew that if i had stuck to
something because the plan was ian if
this didn't work out the next level i
was going to get a kilo of coke and two
guns and
let's play it out till the end of time
just like this of glory whether whether
the [ __ ] blow kills me or somebody
shoots me let's see what happens
and i'm really [ __ ] happy that the
comedy saved me you know so when i got
into it i put a heavy commitment into
this it's like you you've been doing it
23 24 years right like me 24 years at
the eight year mark you're in right
you'll see people in l.a when you got
here and also you forget about those
[ __ ] and you see them on
facebook and you see what the [ __ ]
they're doing now yeah and you sit there
like you go i went to an acting class at
this [ __ ]
i went to a meeting this guy was up for
a show with me he quit it feels like
you're looking at somebody's funeral
they're alive but they're not doing
what you met them doing and you feel sad
that they didn't continue
and it's almost like
like i remember
this is another huge story i was like
hey man
teddy's moving back to new york
he's like teddy's moving back to new
york and he said it like teddy died i
said no he's still alive
but
you're right i think he's moving back to
new york he's dead
and that's how i look at it when i in
that vein that you just mentioned i look
at it that that commitment you told me
you were in it was all fake you were
confused
you came down right you went to montreal
you got the deal
you were at the store you were at the
improv you got to manage and then one
day out of the [ __ ] clear blue sky i
don't see you no more right i don't know
what happened
and then three years later
facebook comes along with twitter and
then you are on facebook talking to lee
and i look and i look at your page and i
see a kid or whatever and i see that
you're at a bowling league now i'm not
mad at you at by no means i don't even
think you're dead i don't even look at
it that way very good and i know they
all miss it like mike rickard misses it
right and michael
all his homies miss it yeah
but
i don't understand how you came out here
and had this commitment
we did all these things you were at the
lab factory with me we did all these
things and one day you just stopped
i never understood that i never
understood it i can't get down i hope i
never get that you know like
i never want to understand it
i just want to keep pushing forward
and just keep this energy that i got to
just keep going forward no i
listen you're a special [ __ ] gem
you're already there it's just you know
that jar right that nobody could open
and your mother comes along with a
missing finger and opens that
[ __ ] that's all that's right at
the point where you're at right now you
and i both know this your talent it's
your time you see a little pushover
uh
you can never
listen man this is going to taste better
for you you didn't come here you wanted
a flat how many flashing pads you know
how many people got a big deal in
montreal they started cutting
[ __ ] at the store
bumping [ __ ] at the store
and now you see them and they can't even
make look at you look at look at that
thing i read five weeks ago about vinnie
favorite when we had to start vinnie
fabrico when you had to start i know
that name who the [ __ ] is that dude who
robbed everybody in vegas he took loans
italian dude
he's a comic
that dude came out here
with a blaze of glory right i mean he
shot every [ __ ] he went to the
straw band went to james masada bang
went to the improv normally the improv
put him up but [ __ ] what's his name
started taking him on tour with him
the old man
who that you know [ __ ] bud friedman
started bringing him everywhere all the
kid was uh went to montreal didn't get a
deal but came back somebody gave him a
tv show he took the magician in with him
and all of a sudden the [ __ ] started
spilling out from everywhere that this
guy had [ __ ] done an open mic class
and boston took everybody's money and
left
he's one of those type of gangsters
then he disappeared from here
then people like no he's in vegas he's
doing [ __ ] great and i'm sitting
there going this dude had a really bad
gambling problem right right and now he
goes to vegas where they just
disappeared and i'm not the type of
guy's going to put them down you just
get like that a guy like that rope right
it's like me going to miami in 95. i
would have been dead right now right
right you don't send joey dears to miami
for no reasons at all in those days the
coke up here is 60. down there it's 25
dollars
you know how many of those like a
[ __ ] day yeah you know it's like they
sent hollywood henderson to miami you're
too young for hollywood anderson right
oh you remember hollywood i don't
remember hollywood henderson was a
[ __ ] bad ass dallas cowboy
badass from the sticks of texas
when i'm typing black [ __ ] i'll
give you the article i'm gonna put it in
my car
this dude sergio ortega gave it to me
and he describes his first day at
thousand oaks
at the training facility right here in
california the dallas cowboys do that
thing up there is that here i am a 20
year old rookie and all i got is 15
three hits acid a gram of blood a couple
of joints and i'm in a dormitory with a
bunch of [ __ ] momos something like
you're like
and from there on dog he talks about
going to the comedy store and picking up
prior and the pointer sisters and
[ __ ] cooking up [ __ ] met uh crack
before you know freebase is what they
called right at 20. he was dog this guy
was ripping it up ahead of his time he
was ahead of his time nobody remembers
the normal let me tell you interesting
story he [ __ ] uh started intercepting
[ __ ] like getting interceptions
and scoring
and then they went to the super bowl
and he took a canned orange crush that's
what they called the denver defense and
then crushed on national tv and then the
super bowl he caught an interception and
ran into the super bowl and that's
[ __ ] was king dick and if you
read like that whole playboy thing he
talks about having an apartment up here
and having three white [ __ ]
having an apartment in dallas
and that for his 27th birthday
and two todd jones gave him four [ __ ]
a red head and an asian black chick and
a [ __ ]
martian and he [ __ ] all four of them i
mean this guy i mean you're sitting
there going holy [ __ ]
and they start talking about [ __ ]
carrying pistols and being up here and
he just went awol so after he wins the
super bowl they all know he's crazy
and if they show old footage of dallas
it's really interesting to see him
because in the locker room after they
won that super bowl you could see him in
the back with no shirt i'm going party
like he was just out there all right he
was 20 years ahead of his time
and then in the game on cbs
he [ __ ] they were losing
and the camera went to him and he went
like this with number one [ __ ]
something mm-hmm next day tom landry cut
his ass don't worry and why do they send
them miami oh and he just went away and
got guns but he got locked up
went to jail came out became a
born-again christian and about six years
ago he won a million dollars in the
texas lottery oh
foreign lucky there you go and [ __ ]
was he on the team that won 16-0
the dallas no that's miami dolphins
that's that's what i meant because you
said he went to miami he went to no no
he went to miami like in 77 and there
were nothing that was way after that no
this happened like in 75 76
you gotta get your [ __ ] together you're
a lot younger you're you're a young man
you don't remember these things and [ __ ]
i don't you know what i suppose it might
not even be an age thing like i was in
jamaica probably when that [ __ ] was
happening so i came on cbs sports yeah
yeah for some reason they didn't have
american football in jamaica
so you know
how many years were you in jamaica nine
two
to seventeen
went to high school down there i went to
high school down there and he was
smoking gun [ __ ] yeah we did it like we
we we're that like a
like a soccer field in my neighborhood
and then there's a
play with like the older dudes and then
there was in jamaica when people start
building a house it could take 20 years
to finish building the house so then
there's this house across the field
across the street from the soccer field
that
it wasn't abandoned it's just that they
had the whole frame up to all the blocks
but it had no windows some of it didn't
have no roof like somebody was like
building it slowly sending money down
and like building it brick by brick so
it was like kind of like a a clubhouse
with no floor
and we just hang out over there i
remember one day it was raining and i
went to the soccer field see if they was
playing and look at the house and
there's smoke coming from out the house
and walk over there all the older soccer
dudes were there and he's passing joints
around smoke with them and [ __ ] and do
stuff like that
let me ask some you know
what's the religion bob marley did
uh rastafarian
and they who's their god
they believe that hayley selassie was a
second coming of christ
but when he sings that song exodus
who's he saying the beginning they
believe in the bible
but they believe that haley selassie is
is the second coming of christ so so so
they believe in the old testament
and
so so they they're kind of christian i
want to like say but there's a lot of
[ __ ] from the bible that they believe
and then they also believe
about
you know that
that
corporate people and
a lot white people did a lot of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and it was about and they
believe in hellish last because there
was a picture of him and his foot
ethiopia was at war with italy and they
beat italy
and uh there's a picture of him
hairless lassie with his foot on this
bomb that didn't explode like a missile
or some [ __ ] and it just was like oh
[ __ ] this motherfucker's god you know
and he just became basically the
rastafarians god rastafarians jesus
christ and i think i'm accurate but you
know you could check it but
and you know it's about just being
healthy and being spiritual and living
good and not hurting people and smoking
dogs and smoking you know just to get
into the consciousness experience you
know spiritual the spiritual thing get
in contact with your higher
consciousness
and not [ __ ] people over and growing
your hair like mama tribe style you know
no [ __ ] being fearless yeah
so you're 17 you end up in new york city
who's up there uh my mother's there and
we all came up me my father my two
sisters and my brother
and uh finished high school in uh
uniondale high school in long island
went there and uh by the coliseum near
the coliseum yeah and i was just like
there's a bunch of jamaicans there hung
out with them because i identified with
them
and then but they was making fun of the
yankee kids
uh
like dominated the school yankees like
any american black kid we we call them
yankees they call us yachties and we
fight every day and if a jamaican person
got into a fight you was in a fight i
was like why are you all starting these
fights
these [ __ ] outnumber us we in america
like why
like are we bad at math
like we're not going to win this fight
after school
there's 10
yards
200 yankees
stop starting these fights
but you got to go fight or else
then you got no friends
it's like being in jail it's like if you
don't fight with your people then you
ain't got no people so you either don't
fight or switch
i can't switch my accent was thick
[ __ ] you was jamaican yesterday
there's no way you ain't jamaican now we
could hear it
so it's just like [ __ ] it
but you know we had fun
and you know we we just just got along
just started knowing people and
spreading had a little job at burger
king making some first i started cutting
lawns
had my own business
and got a little job of burger king and
worked there for a long time stayed
there too long
and uh
like through college and [ __ ]
and i had security guard jobs and
[ __ ] like that as one day when i was at
burger king uh
some dude was on the drive through like
so then i had a problem not a problem
but
learning how to communicate with people
like the way i'm talking to you now
like i had to learn this like i've been
in like when i was a kid in england that
was my comfort zone i was from zero to
nine
all i knew was english you know i'm
saying like hanging around english
people and a lot of those english people
my cousins they were jamaican just but
you just it was a mixed society and you
know how to communicate and talk with
them like they only had whatever radio
stations they had everybody listened to
it you know whatever sports they were
everybody followed it so then you it was
easy to communicate with people and when
you moved to jamaica or when we moved to
jamaica
i knew a lot about jamaica because in
england our parents taught us that so i
and england used to be a colony of
england
so
we had a lot of things in common so then
when i was in jamaica i could easily
relate plus i was interesting because
i'm a [ __ ] from england in jamaica so
people want to talk to you you know what
i'm saying but then when you're jamaican
and you come to america
and you're like
this it's kind of intimidating because
it's all the [ __ ] you've seen on tv
and now you're here in this big ass pot
and like like in jamaica you could feel
the side of the pool
in america there is no side of the pool
you're just in the middle of it and
you're like you got to navigate your way
around this [ __ ] so that's when i
started watching started rooting for the
giants like i learned that people talk
sports and music
and uh
sports music
and
there was a guy there his name was greg
ellis he was funny as [ __ ] he was a
singer
and he was funny as [ __ ] and everybody
loved hanging around
greg and working on his shift at burger
king like this thing would just have you
laughing clowning people
and i enjoyed hanging out with him and i
was like oh that's what you do you just
get funny you tap into your funny side
and you know i was so
just socially lost i forgot that you
know something i was doing naturally in
jamaica
that you know when you're trying to find
your center in a new place
you you forget until it hits you it's
like oh the [ __ ] you was doing in
jamaica [ __ ] just being a person and
being funny and
have some some
context on how to be funny like no
sports no music and because you feel
behind like the things that everybody
knows out here you don't know
you know so you feel behind you're doing
a lot of catching up and you're
pretending to know [ __ ] you don't know
too you know just so you can like fit in
fit in yeah you don't say no it's a
so it's all that [ __ ] going on oh my god
you just took me back
because for me it wasn't as much as the
english
it was
i mean since day one like i i remember
waking up and uh
if you ask me when did this all started
start 127th street
and there
uh i learned how to
i didn't know black and white i just
knew friends
where i lived on 88th street those kids
didn't talk to me because i only my mom
would talk to me in spanish right so
they wouldn't talk to me i don't know
why
but after hanging out with jasper in
that whole scene when i went back to
88th street
and once i got to that school
i was always very timid and quiet i felt
socially unacceptable right i was cuban
i wasn't as good as the white kids you
know you don't know how to fit in yet
you're trying to find it and then who
saved me was my mom
and a kindergarten on my birthday that
[ __ ] brought a carvel cake and a case
of coca-cola and cans the [ __ ]
loved me after that they knew i didn't
[ __ ] around hello i got myself a little
piece ass little chinese girl after that
and i started going
i ain't [ __ ] with you her father used
to draw for charles schultz oh so we get
the first screenings of [ __ ] any
peanut movies she'd take me and would
eat chinese gum
with the raspberries
with the wrapper and we watched it i go
to a house and then something happened
and at that time i was a decent kid i
was very quiet i was very timid
the green hornet came along and i'm
watching this chinese [ __ ] bit
slap people right and i'm like i like
this but i can never do this
this is not my world
i could never see myself lifting up my
hand to another child my mom was an
antagonizer my mom always wanted me to
protect myself right and i go mom i
don't want to hit him my mom would take
me home and go next time i can't push
you gotta punch him in the [ __ ] face
and my mom would have hand signals and
sometimes i'd do it sometimes i wouldn't
when i was in the park
but i got hit in the head with a
flashlight oh central park somebody hit
me took my uh another flashlight a lunch
box right the container and they hit me
and that changed my game because i
didn't like that feeling of getting
beaten the [ __ ] up now i get it while my
mom's saying you got to slip and bit
slap a [ __ ] it was too late i
got the stitches
so after that my hook was being crazy so
if you jumped off the third floor i
jumped off the fifth floor
right if you fought two guys i fought
three guys if you hit him with one egg i
hit him with three eggs right i was one
of those [ __ ] and then i went
up to 148th street
and that's the melting pot it was black
puerto rican irish a couple jews a
couple germans everybody got along it's
like do the right thing
do the right thing as a beautiful movie
because about people just talking out
loud but deep down inside we all get
along with one of them we have to
communicate with one another every
[ __ ] day i got to go to your korean
store you got to walk by me to get
[ __ ] shoes you know
there's interaction no there's
interaction that you don't know about
even though i'm sitting on the corner
going those [ __ ] puerto ricans those
[ __ ] [ __ ] meanwhile i'm at the
corner with him hugging him giving him a
dollar so he'd get a bottle right
because that's how i roll but you follow
me
if they get along you just get along and
that's where i got that little melting
pot is where
i just got hit like i knew that you had
to back your friends right you know if
you want to be [ __ ] whatever if
somebody's [ __ ] with leon on there
and there's eight [ __ ] you want
people to not [ __ ] with you jumping for
lee and bit slap that's it right you're
the leader of this crew now you're
giving orders
you're hanging out with the other
leaders and [ __ ] so that's the way i
knew i never knew it was about being
funny right i never had an idea that
came in later on
the odd couple but but being like
jumping from the fourth window when
somebody jumps from the third that [ __ ]
is funny like you're doing a lot of
funny [ __ ] but you don't know how much
you're entertaining people
you know you you're entertaining people
more than scaring the [ __ ] out of them
you know what i'm saying like this this
month like
you're the you know you're the crazy
funny [ __ ] you know but you are
identifying with the crazy part but
people are like this [ __ ]
entertainer i like to hang around this
[ __ ] he's amazing do you
remember the 45 singles
yeah the records yeah yeah okay my mom
had a jukebox at the bar so when the 45
singles were done she'd keep them in a
box when i went to her record shop i'd
take the 45 singles and put them in a
bag and take them home what are you
going to do i'm going to listen to them
i'm going to listen to them i go to my
back window and there'd be people out
there walking
there was a parking garage back there
and i whipped those things out of there
and hit [ __ ] in the head
and for months nobody knew who it was
i would go off and the kids would be
saying yeah man
some of these whipping [ __ ] records
that [ __ ] out there he cut this
guy he hit this guy in the head he hit
this guy's dog and finally
one day i told like these few little
gangsters i go if i tell you a secret
you won't say that i'm like i'm the
[ __ ] that's been launching those
45s out the window like come on
no and i could come upstairs i had boxes
out
these [ __ ] went nuts i gave
them like a ham and cheese sandwich i
love them up there throwing those things
out the window for like an hour oh my
god you were a terror
i said it's crazy but it's fun
you know what i'm saying
like throwing records and eating ham and
cheese oh my god for an hour oh these
little puerto rican kids where you gonna
find fun like that no that was my whole
thing i was always
i wasn't one of these okay i wasn't a
bad kid
i just loved to rock right like at that
age even at that age with the with the
broken english i was a professional in
new york city they had trees but in the
spring they would come with these
[ __ ] dirt balls there were these
little fertilizer [ __ ] arab balls
that's how they bought the world trade
center with these little things and they
were like man-made dirt and they put it
around the tree
and then it would after the rain they
would sink in and break in those things
when they hit you they would hit you
they hurt a little bit but they blow up
so you'd have dust all over your [ __ ]
right dawg i would launch those little
[ __ ] things
i hit a [ __ ] puerto rico with
an ice cube he should have been a
pitcher oh my god from the eighth floor
at the whole time you were tonight
people
from the eighth floor in a puerto rican
hotel with my family i went upstairs i
started throwing ice cubes off the roof
and some dude was walking and that ice
cream cube caught momentum and like
knocked that [ __ ] out
and they were looking to see who was
doing and they knocked on my door and
they knew for the look on my face i was
guilty
to say that that's amazing you said
something to me the other day you said
like you're gonna be like humber's gonna
come back at you with mercy like
my daughter i know for a fact i was
from four to seven man i was brutal
after my dad died mm-hmm you know you
lose your dad you got no control my mom
didn't know what to do my mom was crazy
so she gave it back to me i would
overpower a regular woman right right at
that age it was just a it was a horror
show what i did to my mom and i wasn't a
bad kid i just missed my dad right once
she remarried that calmed me down mm-hmm
and then did you accept that dude right
away
yes i did it was the weirdest thing
because i had i yearned for a man
you know i was always around women and
[ __ ]
i liked it but ah
after a while i'm smelling perfume and
people kissing me i got lipstick on they
call me my [ __ ] hair
i want to learn how to sling dick jack
so now you're in jamaica and uh whatever
you mentioned something about the the 45
records like yeah in jamaica
so
my we used to live in this place called
church plant pen
and there's this town called old harbor
it's like
one mile walk and my father worked at
the end of old hob at the soybean
factory like he was an engineer over
there and at night my my sisters used to
cook
and then one of us had to take him the
food for dinner
and uh
so it was my turn and we could give us
bus fare but if you walk the mile and
walk the mile back you get to keep the
bus
and then there was this record that was
hot on the radio at the time this
regular
record and [ __ ] so i said i'm a walk
there and back by the record and walk
back and then we get home my father's
gonna be at work me and my brother's
just gonna just play this [ __ ] all night
so then i get to old harbor walk give
him the food
say goodbye stop at the radio the the
record stop get the get the get the 45
i'm running home not paying attention
all i'm thinking about this and somebody
had dug up
the fire hydrant that was on the
sidewalk and they left the hole that was
filled with water
oh no i
fell
like a kid fell in in the middle of the
night and we don't have street lights
so i'm like one minute i'm running and
the next minute i'm like
ray charles little brother
yeah i'm like i'm like drowning with a
record trying to
trying to trying to hold it above the
holes
so it doesn't
i had to climb out that [ __ ] muddy
hole
and then and then make it the rest of
the way home they're like what the [ __ ]
happened to you i don't know i don't
know just put this record on and we just
played that [ __ ] all night
it's just [ __ ] like that
it's a crazy [ __ ] world jamaica
what club did you go up first time uh
first time was uh
i worked in east meadow at burger king
so the club
that the guy said that chuckles no i was
uh
chuckles i did chuckles too like iceland
chuckles and but governors was the first
one sorry to go back and forth between
east meadow and that east meadow east
meadows where governor's at and chuckles
and
is it mineola or some [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
chase do that
grandpa's in staten island
did i i never really [ __ ] with staten
island like that i would go to yonkers
though
what was in yoga's uh shooting stars or
some [ __ ] like that was black white
white club white club they'd have mics
you know nights where
you know it wasn't the weekend but you
know like maybe five or ten people would
show up in the audience and we just give
them all our bad comedy just
beat them beat the
try to get all the bad [ __ ] out of us
you know try to do good some of us would
some night you'd be very inconsistent
was frustrating
and
some nights most nights first like three
four years of comedy they wouldn't even
be crowds sometimes sometimes like you
wouldn't wrong for weeks
yeah you get to a spot and there's like
no show tonight you wait around no show
so you just go eat
and talk [ __ ]
who was around back then what year was
this when you're getting on stage for
the first couple times trying to
remember who was around i know i used to
go to the comic comic strip to try to
pull the the belongings right the
numbers
and i know
sam so when i always get a number
because you know the guy that used to
give the numbers out and i don't know
man it was a guy he got killed like
mondays right mondays or something you
went to you went there you get on on a
monday but you went there the first
friday of every month they would do the
lotto
you imagine that way all right so you so
if you're a young kid or whatever you
want to
get
a spot on that stage for that month you
have to there's a long line of like bad
comics including me
and you go up to the podium and they
have
pieces of paper turned over some of them
had numbers some of them didn't you got
a piece of paper with a number
then they'd give you
a spot on one monday for that month and
i'd go
wait online and it was a big thing to me
like the first time i went there like i
wanted to get a number how many amazing
how many did they have how many like
numbers did they have
not
maybe
maybe like i don't know i can't i never
never thought about it maybe 13 numbers
wow for the whole month
you know and and you you drive to
manhattan it's a big thing and you want
to get on and then you're online you're
moving up you're moving up then it's
your turn and the first time i picked up
a piece of paper had no number and i
[ __ ] i just came all the way here for
nothing i'm not gonna get on and then i
just went back on the back of the line i
was like i gotta try again
and then you get there now there's only
like three pieces of paper left and it
was you didn't get a number when there
was more paper
why why the [ __ ] would you get a number
now
so then i'm looking at the papers people
are behind me like [ __ ] hurry up and
pick a hurry up and not pick a number so
we can not pick a number
and then i'm like looking at the thing
there was a piece of nut there was a
piece of paper in the corner and it's
just so funny how much
how big of a decision this was picking
up one of these pieces of paper because
you just needed to get on
and i went for right here like right at
the corner podium and there was a number
on it and i got a spot
and then
every time i went to the comic strip
to pick a number on the first friday
every month i would always pick it from
that corner and there was always a
number
and i would get a spot and then i'd see
adam sadler chris rock come through or
just
just you know just just people you seen
on tv had names and you you i'd stay
i do my spot they tell me now we're not
gonna make you a regular but let's stay
in that fishbowl section and just watch
like
people you've seen on tv and you're a
kid
and you're like
having the time of your life
trying to make it like
you at least you can see some end
results and
and you have friends that you went to
high school with but they're not doing
this what you're doing they didn't see
adam sadler that night they didn't see
chris rock they didn't see seinfeld or
whoever came in they're not living the
life you live and you start separating
from them because you actually feel
special even though you're brokered in
them you know what i mean you're like
your life is never going to be
filled with laughter like mine i can't
really [ __ ] with you like that
and then
i remember one friday i went to pick
numbers and i was insecure
because i picked like five numbers in a
row from this corner spot and i was like
there's nowhere it's gonna be here again
and i and i said let me i panicked and i
grabbed something from the middle there
was no number and i was like [ __ ] i
should have picked from the from the
corner i got back on the line and i was
like praying please don't let nobody
pick a piece of paper from that corner
and i went back
and i there was a piece of paper in the
corner and i picked it there was a
number on it and then from then on i
never didn't pick from the car [ __ ] no
always got on i always got on they never
passed it but i always got on
i never had the patience to wait on a
line like that like i know like that
laugh factory [ __ ] he puts you through
when you first move oh yeah yeah
i did that one time and i felt so
[ __ ] degrading like i was like if i
got to do that i ain't doing it right i
just won't work that [ __ ] clock that
line's a different line that line's a
crazy line
like
from my memory the line of the comics
comic comic strip in new york those were
comics those are comics you're
absolutely correct
people got on costumes
people people are homeless people are
like
i got nothing to do with comedy or
should have nothing to do with comedy or
not like i said the people go to the
comedy store on monday nights right
seven to ten then half of them have
mental illness yeah don't take a [ __ ]
genius to know that you're sitting there
going joey you're [ __ ] up too yeah but
these people are really really [ __ ] up
boom chuckalacka shows up with a [ __ ]
uh
uh a thing a shopping cart yeah jeff
richards puts him in videos and that
crazy bastard
boom chuckalacka the other guy who comes
late night and he's a nazi and he goes
in the bathroom they let him on fire
michael eppaway whatever his [ __ ]
name is i don't know i don't even know
if he still comes to this yeah i don't
think so i got a call one day joey why'd
you like
epivei on fire last night in the
bathroom that wasn't me that was don
barris
i guess he hated jews or
he was german oh i know that guy the
german he's coming at night you go like
this to him
he's weird as [ __ ] yeah he's weird i
know that guy so they would wait for him
to go to the baton and lock him in there
from outside and then they would throw
fire in the [ __ ] thing
it's like he's in the prison cellar
set him on fire and [ __ ]
try to frag him i never tried to light
up my phone i was out there laughing
don't get me wrong you know
don barris and a bunch of other guys are
trying to light him on [ __ ] fire and
stuff
is that frustrating though like
your career isn't
based on like how good you are it's if
you pick the number like for the first
two that must be really frustrating
you do what you can in the beginning
until you start to figure it out there
was a an open mic in san francisco at
the punch line on sunday nights and
people would go up there and they would
put you on a list but there was no name
there was no numbers
the guy would come up to you five
minutes before and go you're next and he
would walk past you and glare at you i
did it one time i told he got to go [ __ ]
something
like a [ __ ] life factory and i don't
remember me [ __ ] and he was like [ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] you [ __ ] tonight
you trying to [ __ ] with us
[ __ ] you [ __ ] doing that to a
comedian you know people don't do that
that's the respect fact i didn't like
about the beginning of comedy right and
then here you get even worse until you
book something right see that's what i
always tell young comments when they
come out i try to book something i don't
care well i don't care if you got to
suck ten dicks just get out of the way
now
book song
book something it's not that people see
you the the booking agents and they give
you a little work at the improv is even
what i'm saying you know i give you a
little love but it's all based on that
they don't give a [ __ ] how funny y'all
oh this guy's gonna be fun you know what
if this guy booked the [ __ ] part on
uh
what's the show with vergara or american
family even if it's a plumber and people
say you booked a role on that guess what
he might book a role in a pilot that's
[ __ ] seinfeld and here we're gonna
turn him down no that's not going to
happen it's like when you go to jail and
you write letters of recommendation
if you get a judge that has political
aspirations that guy every letter them
is 250 people because when you die
they make 250 mass cards everybody knows
at least 250 people dentists lawyers
communists so every time you send a if i
send a letter in in lee's behalf because
you're a swindler you're really bernie
madoff i gave him a hundred bucks last
week he lost it all in vegas i invested
in this [ __ ] he walked away he
was a stock fraud he told me
i said well let me let me stake this guy
for 20 points i'm saying nothing he came
back with rabbit ears walked away there
he is and don't walk away
how long were you in new york for
running and gunning before somebody took
notice of you uh i was there until like
like i said like 99
i just like so the first thing was keen
library wayne first the first like i've
done it's like some like they had an
uptown comic club tv show
and i did like stan that was 125th
street yeah
i remember that
i don't think so that place used to
scare me too like i used to go there i
used to cop right down behind my bro
it was a health food store mr wendell oh
i think i remember that wasn't that jam
was i missed a win it was an old dude
he would always give me chocolate thai
wheat and i always try to shoplift one
from his hand like a magician i thought
that
there's only a 20 in here
it's hilarious all right so you did
uptown comedy club you come out here
mm-hmm then you get like bad boys at
comedy yeah the bad boys and i did def
jam back in new york too i was deaf jam
def jam was it was great to do but by
the time i did it
it didn't have the effect that it used
to have
so
did a good set but
nothing who was the host uh then martin
wasn't hosting the first time i did it
so you just missed that window yeah it
was the most thing who was the winner oh
who hosted that episode i think oh
what's his name joe torrey i think was a
host of that show
joe toy was the warm-up all right first
but then
he ended up being a host yeah when i
first started comedy that was one of the
first uh
tapes i got oh right the best of death
jam with uh the kid from jersey bill
bellamy bill bellamy and one of the guys
at joe torreira until this day i just
saw joe torre i always tell him that
joke about
my brothers who save the whale type
[ __ ] me
i bought a gun for protection [ __ ] i go
to the atm and i dressed up in a tuxedo
with a gun
you know [ __ ] like that i laughed my ass
off when i heard that at first that was
one of the first things i bought i
really liked bet i really wasn't on bt
it was on hbo i saw a lot of [ __ ]
people blow up a room but i'm gonna tell
you who's the most memorable person i've
ever seen blow up a room on there mm-hmm
d.l
oh okay as an emcee right which is tough
he just took that [ __ ] room and
[ __ ] them up
[ __ ] them [ __ ] people up to pieces
i never seen that many people bl
dog the best place i ever saw him he was
on 178th street i was telling lydia then
i went to see rambo that movie theater
was packed with black
people 1985 and he got the russian and
he opens his eyes in the mud
dog black people who were [ __ ]
jumping up and down that movie theater
there we go that white boy is a bad
[ __ ] i told you i told you talk
told that white [ __ ] was bad
though it was hysterical that's
hilarious i saw him that's what i saw
d.o.u we blow up
he [ __ ] took it apart man
yeah that's your mad stars mad star man
stars you got on
even if you didn't become a star you'd
be on that tour
you're making money so you know i was
like seeing people get their [ __ ] off on
it and i was just dying to get out but i
wasn't i wasn't even ready
danny
then yet either you know i was still
like working on my [ __ ] trying to figure
out and then finally had a set
together and i and i got on you know but
it was just missed that window
you know
and i did it twice
yeah i did it twice i did it again where
it was like a all-star show
and that was like
now one of them
yeah both of them i had dreads on both
of them okay one was just longer dreads
and [ __ ]
and then i
did good on that one too but nothing the
show just just didn't have the power it
used to have
were you disappointed
it's not disappointing like if i knew
what i knew now then i could have did
something with it but you you just
didn't know you decided you did the set
it's gonna air i'm gonna get these phone
calls nothing
and there was no social media there's no
social media either there was no there's
nothing you could do
you know you could do yeah that's crazy
there was no media didn't you have a
similar experience with long least yard
yeah that's why it's kind of weird when
you do something you're expecting so
much in return yeah and nothing happens
and i tell people that was my breaking
point like eight months after that once
that movie came on dvd
and i was still getting problems with
auditions i i didn't know how to handle
it right i didn't know and then i see
tracy morgan on tv after it and [ __ ]
the black dude with muscles that
[ __ ] scored that movie that's
his whole career
terry crews yeah yeah
and here i am living on [ __ ]
schroeder in hollywood and [ __ ]
back by uh what's the selma
you know when you're living by somebody
you're [ __ ] up shit's not right it's
shady that's a shady block that's a
shady [ __ ] block not anymore let's
start cleaning it up not anymore now
they cleaned it up
so now what cd did you do that conan
produced it uh last year
i did a did my first comedy album and i
was me and my manager i got a good
manager now his name is hunter seidman
like he uh like i said if i i had
managers where hey man these people
like me they want to do something they
say all right cool cool and then they'll
never investigate it like people who
didn't care or if you did something
and
you could make something out of it
they just they just didn't care or
follow any leads i don't know what the
[ __ ] they were doing unless they get the
leads
sometimes they don't want to [ __ ] with
it it's really weird it's stupid if they
don't know from a to z they're like ah
we called but the guy sounded fishy then
you bump into the dude a year later
you're like dog your manager never
called me right we didn't think you want
to do the project and you're like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about right
like when i did basketball one day as
the third day i was in the center like
hey man
we called the comedy store looking for
you for mafia
remember they did the movie with jay
moore married the italian people like 98
i was passed
i was passed the guy goes yeah we called
the store twice we talked to the guy the
talent coordinator
by that time he was fired oh [ __ ] by
that time he was a goofy [ __ ] he was
only there for like two months he was
drinking and [ __ ] so yeah that pisses
you the [ __ ] off yeah these are like
opportunities and [ __ ] that you know
could move you further up the ladder and
you're like well you know [ __ ] it but
what was the question you asked anyway
no so you're on conan so i'm on so conan
came at me
and i guess the reason why because conan
liked me from before and i'd done the
show
three times and then third time i did it
they was like hey we're planning on like
starting a record label and we're
thinking about
one though you will ever record on an
album if you want to do one and we could
talk about doing one with you and i was
like all right i'm trying to do one but
this is probably the best place to do it
and i'm i'm excited and i like the fact
that you like me like that that you want
to [ __ ] with me like that so yeah i'll
[ __ ] with you let's do it
and so
we taped it in la jolla at the comedy
store
and then released it last may
it's called 100 half-assed and it's at
team coco teamcocorrecos.com
it's like [ __ ] it
and then now
i got to do a special you know i got
like another hour already and uh with
all the stuff there's some of the stuff
you mentioned i just got to get that
[ __ ] together and do it because you got
to put your content out there and you
got to i got to get my social life you
guys you got your social media stuff
together like i'm like i'm terrible with
that i got to get better at that like
this like this industry is not going to
help me so i got to do as much as i can
to help you have an agent i got a
manager no agent writing agent no
literary agent nah my stuff is like
referrals
and from like
like writing on shows and other writers
or these young comics getting deals and
then like they see me at the store
and like you're a good writer you're
written on shows you want to work with
me like that's how jerrod you know hit
me up
and he's like you know he's
here's a funny story about gerard like
remember when facebook myspace was out
uh
some people used to hit me up randomly
on myspace like you know because some
people see me on deaf jamming them shows
and they hit you up say hey man i'm
thinking about doing comedy uh you know
what should i do
and should i move out to la and blah
blah and i say yeah if you want to do it
come on move out here and you when you
get here just hustle and grind and take
this thing serious and blah blah blah
blah and
gerard was one of those people that hit
me
and i had no idea he just told me and we
hung out
since he got here for a few years and he
just told me
maybe this year hey man i was that dude
that hit you up on myspace and you told
me to come out here
isn't that [ __ ] crazy crazy if you
think about it then you did get
something from doing the deaf damn show
yeah yeah yeah it's just like way later
that's so cool yeah
that's true i've always told you that
these little guys are my future yeah
these young cats one of them is going to
papa shunga i want you to be my own yeah
your uncle and the show's going to be a
number one hit and yeah i was
jerking myself to [ __ ] off for years
doing this and that and that's how this
game works you know
people truly
i learned one thing as a comic that when
you wanted something really bad and
started like as a comic you wanted to go
to montreal right and then you don't go
well sometimes you do go and you're like
all that [ __ ] for nothing right i put
all that [ __ ] in for nothing for years i
wanted to play catch a rising star yeah
yeah for years i wanted to play the one
in reno and vegas and i [ __ ]
tormented that guy he kept telling me no
no no i saw your tape you're dirty blah
blah and then when they got a call from
jimmy schubert hey dawg i need a feature
for reno
what the [ __ ]
for years i've been trying to torture
this [ __ ] guy and now you're gonna
walk me in there hilarious no tape no
nothing you know what i'm saying like
everybody has a feature act they want to
see your tape you never know
that's the best thing about this game
right
that you never know what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen i call it entertainment
lotto but the only way you can win if
you keep playing every day as long as
you put your heart into this thing like
today i tell people on the first of the
month we're all equal all right you
ain't better than me i ain't better than
you because we're all working for the
same dollar
so guess what i'm the first we're all
the same it's what you do on the second
that [ __ ] matters right
so what do you think [ __ ] how high
are you look at the shape of you pretty
high yeah look at his face look at his
face he got sun yesterday yeah
[ __ ] next time he goes jews go to the
beast's umbrella you know he talked
about
next time get a little umbrella for you
that'd be nice
this is really interesting man i always
wanted to have you on i didn't know this
much about you
it's my pleasure
you're a gentleman you know but what you
do on stage man is [ __ ]
comedy jazz that's just uh there's a
timing and there's smoothness to it
mm-hmm
and that's it man i think you're one of
the best working man
i've been really fortunate i went back
to the store and you guys elevated me
like you made me savages again because i
got to follow you guys right in the last
couple weeks i i feel in my heart i've
had some of the best comments i've had
from you and sebastian and
you know and i didn't see you back then
joe's known you enjoy raves about you
and
i started watching you at the store and
going jesus [ __ ] christ now i know
this guy's game is [ __ ] tight the
writing is a 10.
sometimes i sit there and i go gee what
am i watching you know and i tell him
all the time i always aspired to that
but i was too lazy outright but i get
too lazy and mm-hmm that's just a
special gifting comment you know i have
high energy i trick you with the high
energy and the voice and that [ __ ] and
you fall for it
you know everybody has smoke and [ __ ]
mirrors you have no smoking mirrors so
you know me dog i'm on the [ __ ] uh
i'm on the ian edwards [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're a bad [ __ ] thanks
man the story we're kicking his glory
you know what i'm saying no more rock
stop a little public enemy at least i
yeah what's up with you tom no it's
crazy because
one of the best parts about my job is i
get to go and watch a lot of comedy and
what i've noticed is
the best comics are the ones you like
remember like their bits you say their
name you can think of stuff they've said
and when paul asked me who was on
tonight i thought of like three or four
of his bits and it just
it's uh
i think that's a quality that's like you
you have it too like people remember
certain bits that you say
because otherwise it's just a nervous
[ __ ] otherwise it's just like oh he's a
dirty comic or oh he's a clean comic
it's boring it's a very interesting life
we put together for ourselves yeah every
morning i have a little thing
and i write my thoughts after my coffee
and [ __ ] and there's one thought that
always sticks out that
i'm happy this thing worked out i'm
happy that my life worked out
it worked out you know uh
whatever it worked out you have no idea
where i was 20 years ago 30 years ago
it worked out whatever's going on you
know the the the walls on the office
aren't painted
you know my car is dirty it smells like
sweat right but everything else worked
out bro and uh
that's big especially when you come from
another country you took me back tonight
with some words that you said because i
remember not the pain it's not a pain
that you think about later on in your
life right
it was just
i never thought i was gonna get beat up
because i was spanish i never thought
none of that [ __ ] right but i always
thought i was a little not worthy
right like i look at kids and go ah you
know i'll never have that and then
i don't know i don't know what the [ __ ]
i know that feeling you know that
feeling and i know what you were saying
like well you try to fit in jesus
[ __ ] christ how hard is that you know
you're gonna fit in
and i knew who i was in new york
you know when i got to jersey they just
put [ __ ]
gasoline on me you know that was it
where were you doing comedy in jersey in
those days where did you go to that
contest you said oh that contest i
forgot where that contest was but i know
they had peppermint lounge
and that was like a crazy place to
perform there's this other spot named
terminal d
where if
you got booked at terminal d the two
weeks before that show you were ruined
because of the fear
of having to do that show it was a long
dark room
and
you couldn't see the audience and
when you went on that stage there was a
like two rows
from the front there was a cowbell with
a long piece of rope it was in the
ceiling but the rope was hanging out it
was usually like some [ __ ] state
troopers sitting at the cowbell table so
if you're performing
they could just ring that bell and
everybody start pulling it like we're
done with this [ __ ]
get him get him out so so you have to go
there knowing you could get cowbelled
i had a friend his name was pat
uh
he's like
pat was like six feet
400 pounds used to lie to me that he was
200 pounds but i didn't know weight back
then
and uh
and uh
he
we we had a [ __ ] we performed up there
one night he went on
and his closer
is
he went to his closer in his second joke
that's how bad he was doing you know you
do you do your first joke no response so
you know if i do the second joke
that's not as strong as my closer which
is my best joke i'm gonna get booed
they're gonna bring that clown bell so
he was so desperate to to win them
he went to his
last joke his closer and his closer was
imagine a 400 pound guy laying
across a stool with his arm spread and
his joke was
this is this is me at the macy's day
parade
which is which is funny
which is funny but dave was not having
it no no no no no no a 400 pound dude
is laying across a stool with his arm
spread and you hear the bell going
it's like the the embarrassment of like
you like you you're selling out for the
joke you're all out you're you're spread
out and they're like nah guys
it's like going off your favorite team's
game a championship game you got the
jersey on they get beat and they get
there you gotta walk down back to that
car with that jersey on that's a long
[ __ ] walk though that's why i don't
commit to [ __ ] jerseys jack that's
too much commitment in my [ __ ] world
[ __ ] you there was this dude who's the
really popular black writer in town
warren hutchinson no john ridley no
he writes on a lot of older shows
guys
oh
there's a [ __ ] wow antoine [ __ ] no
[ __ ]
yeah yeah
he had an uh one of his dudes had an
idea about an italian cop that was a
kung fu teacher
it was the worst
idea i ever heard he was adamant about
it this brother was a good dude but
he'd buy me lunch and tell me how this
was me he could get the meeting set up
but i had to go for a tailor and i can
really tell him because i want to i want
you to walk into the meeting with an
authentic
chinese kung fu uniform i said dog
that's where it stopped
i mean the show was so [ __ ] bad but
he had great representation right right
so he got me meetings everywhere
his [ __ ] assistant sent me a list one
day and i had like three pictures a day
for two [ __ ] weeks i ain't paying him
we went every day after the second day i
told him come here listen
six people i mean to the point where
they didn't even let us finish yeah
they're like you know what we have at 4
15. oh my god
we'll talk we'll call your agent nice to
meet you boom
it was horrible all of a sudden the
meeting popped up in the middle of the
meeting it's um it's amazing the worst
people have the top representation like
this guy was like they love it he took
me there one day i think it was like on
wilshire a lot of [ __ ] yarmulkes we
went in that dog he gave it to me like
we love it you as a kung fu teacher you
work with the mayor
and he your vigilante and you saved kids
it was [ __ ] horrible
and they weren't gonna let me do it
anyway there's no way
no [ __ ] way
and he kept saying you gotta wear the
kung fu uniform that'll pull them over
and i'm like dog i ain't wearing no
[ __ ] uniform i'm the [ __ ]
bearing my lock i would never sell out
i'd rather be at the store pushing
fifteen dollars right right man thank
you again my brother some sponsors and
we'll get the [ __ ] we'll get you the
[ __ ] out of here number one as always
the best on it
went to jiu jitsu today took two [ __ ]
honor pills from jiu jitsu i went to the
[ __ ] north hollywood park and i did
some [ __ ] kettlebells with 10 more
pounds you understand me i was out there
huffing and puffing and when i got
finished with dirt i put the kettlebell
in the trunk of the [ __ ] car and i
brought back with a 15-pound dumbbell
and i proceeded to do uh sit-ups with
all this [ __ ] uh what are we talking
about
on it on it not on it but uh aqualung
what's the name of this building alpha
bring
and that's how [ __ ] much oxygen i had
in my [ __ ] lungs so if you're lacking
with your cardio you want a little bit
more help to stretch them out the
quadricep mushrooms shroom tech sport is
for you [ __ ] but don't stop
there we base everything on alpha brain
100 money back guarantee
that's our bread and butter right there
you ever go to a chinese restaurant you
don't eat the pork fried rice don't give
me the money back
they tend to go [ __ ] yourself and they
spit in the [ __ ] soup that's what i'm
saying alpha brain gives you the money
back we don't even want the product back
do me a favor go to honor.com right now
and press in church boom
c-h-u-r-c-a
and get 10 percent off your first order
and just stay on it they'll mail this
[ __ ] to your house every [ __ ] month
they'll take it out of your [ __ ]
credit card whatever number two
one of my favorites hit e6
you don't want cancer you got to go the
electronic weight [ __ ] suckers they got
24 16 8 milligrams and zero if you're
thinking of quitting smoking cigarettes
and they got one of the best [ __ ]
e-cigars on the market not only that
1200 guaranteed pups joey stop it i go
to 7-eleven i got like eight pups from
those hindu cigarettes pumped that i got
hitti six 1200 guaranteed pups
i'm out of puffs
i took the wrong one
who's better than me right now
i'm looking like sinatra at universal
studios
go to h86.com right now
and press in joey's church and get
twenty percent off
there's the fifty four five oh [ __ ] i'm
gonna give you five for five dollar
fifty five for fifty
five for fifty they usually 18 dollars
[ __ ] that scratch it i'm gonna give you
a whole pack this is what you're gonna
do
hold on one second i gotta clear out the
[ __ ] lungs you're gonna get so
excited you're gonna get the zero eight
sixteen and twenty four and i'm gonna
give you a cigar for 50 [ __ ] bucks
all right you're going to be puffing
till [ __ ] saint smidgeon today go to
86.com right now and press in joey's
shirt boom and get a deal five for five
fifty five for fifty for fifty [ __ ]
dollars all right beautiful 1200
guaranteed pubs and also to my goombas
from west new york new jersey nailed
their life aka
please give me some honest are you
kidding me or what that's a jew talking
spanish
los gumi's models what's the web page so
you go directly to life. nailed it
life.com go there the best paper pen
in the [ __ ] market they got a ton of
other stuff there you're gonna love it
if you're a dab user if you like losing
your mind listen to music and smoking
foreign objects in a [ __ ] pen
they got the [ __ ] background on the
marker for you you understand me why not
you put some [ __ ] i love smoking for
an object oh my god i love that glass
and all that [ __ ] you smoking those
paper pens the best vapor pen in the
market you got torches in the car go to
nail their life dot com right now and
press enter ideas and get 20
off you understand me that's how they
roll and let's not forget iron dragon tv
bring you the classic martial art films
go to iron dragon tv right now and press
in joey and get two free [ __ ] movies
right now on the arm when was the last
time you watched the classic martial
arts film tell me the truth then the
never [ __ ] sucker you know why because
you're sitting there jerking on [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] get into something do
something with your life when was the
last time you learned about chinese
culture and broken eyes and flying
through the [ __ ] air on strings go to
irondragontv.com and press enter joey
and get two free rentals boom just like
that don't give me your two movies i'm
giving you 20 off for nails in life i'm
giving you five for 50 on hitting stakes
and i'm giving you 100.com 10 off your
orders all right people i want to thank
ian edwards for coming on my pleasure my
main man lisa where you gonna be are you
on the road yet
you got a guy booking you on the road uh
yeah i got some spot days i'm gonna be
at bonnaroo and uh i'm gonna be at the
montreal comedy festival just came from
hawaii and uh yeah i'm like what are you
doing or what i did uh this dude named
uh shane price the comic out there i did
like 11 this club called 1144. so i
headlined out there wasn't a comedy club
but it's a nice spot and they put some
shows together and he's got greg not
greg he's got a
damn it todd barry coming out there and
some other people i'll put you in
contact nice nice he listens to the
whole death squad crew and all that
stuff yeah great to be going to hawaii i
think lee and throw him off the [ __ ]
plane you won't take me i'll take it i'm
telling you i'm taking you i'm gonna
drop you off on an island with bigger
wines
with little dicks with diet pills you
know what i'm saying
around for three [ __ ] days
all right man let's end this
[ __ ] lee put some music on for
we'll be back wednesday night
8 p.m i love you guys thank you for
listening thank you for your networks i
love you guys stay black i'm going to be
in denver this weekend thursday through
saturday and then the 18th and the 19th
i'm going to be at
salt lake city of [ __ ] wise
guys did i give shout outs tonight no he
didn't no i did not what the [ __ ] was i
thinking
and your dad i love you
chris trenton the boys over there
[ __ ] making the cars lawn rosica stan
hang in there tom hortons a good deal
yeah he is frank berdini kanye joe ellie
o'neill
freddie corriere
pat shea and my main man chris short
happy birthday cod sugar and that's it
we'll be back wednesday night for you
guys thank everybody thank israel in the
morning joint on periscope in the
morning join on periscope four days a
week smoking reefer
dropping you out of the house with
inspirational thoughts you know how i do
it i love you cox stay black